let's talk about what is known in Latin
as post hoc ergo propter hoc this
translates in english as after this
therefore because of this this is also
known simply as the post hoc fallacy
let's say this I live on a farm and I
have a rooster every morning right
before sunrise the rooster crows can I
conclude from this that the rooster
causes the Sun to come up every day
that's a famous example that's used to
illustrate the post hoc fallacy we have
a post hoc fallacy when an argument
assumes that just because one event
occurred after another that there must
be a causal link between these two
events just because event B followed
event a then event B must have been
caused by event a so to break down the
fallacy the premise is a occurred before
B the conclusion is therefore a caused B
if there is an implicit premise that
assumes when a occurs before B then a
causes B because and only because a
occurs before B then we have a post hoc
fallacy the argument is invalid and this
is what's known as a causal fallacy or a
questionable cause fallacy because a
cause is being misidentified in order to
make this argument valid we would need
to take that implicit premise and
replace it with actual reasons why a
causes B a causes B because X or because
Y or because Z then it might be safe to
say that a causes B obviously a given
event can be the cause of another event
that closely follows but not merely
because it occurred first a further case
needs to be made in order to make that
link but the post hoc fallacy can be
especially tempting to make because as
humans our perceptions often fall back
on instinct if we're not careful events
in close succession
can easily appear to suggest causality
just take all of the parents who believe
that vaccines caused their child's
autism essentially only because the
autism symptoms appeared after the child
was vaccinated the human mind is always
looking to connect dots when it comes to
sequences and causality the child was
doing just fine before and soon after
the vaccines the child started showing
signs of autism someone arguing a post
hoc fallacy is often failing to
entertain the possibility of a
coincidence or that the second event or
circumstance may have caused the first
event or that there are other unknown
factors relating to the two events this
miniseries is made possible in part by
brilliant if you want to become an even
better critical thinker you should check
out this online learning service
brilliant is a site where you can learn
about logic fallacies multi-level
thinking and countless other topics
related to philosophy mathematics and
science
what sets brilliant apart is that you're
actually learning by working hands-on
with real-life problems one of their
principles is effective learning is
active and this makes a lot of sense
there's a ton you can learn from passive
activities reading books watching online
videos but you're never really taking
your understanding to the next level and
applying what you're learning until
you're able to work with real-world
scenarios and that's what brilliant
allows you to do master anything from
probability to physics to the concepts
of artificial intelligence and
everything in between
sign up for free by going to brilliant
org slash critical thinking I've put a
link in the description under this video
and the first 200 people who visit that
URL will get 20% off an annual
membership visit brilliant org slash
critical thinking